Let's imagine that your
product looks amazing.
Everything's working smoothly,
the colors are awesome, but
the revenue stream is low.
What could be the problem?
>> There could be a number of roadblocks
that prevent users from spending
money in your app.
A roadblock could be a design issue
that discourage users, for example,
a complex registration form, or
a user exceptions on particular devices.
You can use the reports we've talked
about in the previous lessons
to help you identify the road block, and
more effectively monetize your users.
Let's take a look at a few examples
that will help us investigate and
find the reasons.